you recorded
co-ceo of daily wire Jeremy boring on a
phone call he says I thought we were
friends a lot of people have said wow
that that was a mess of thing to do it
sounds like what you're saying in in the
context we're just talking
they sent you a business contract that
was very bad that penalized you 110 if
all all fees are applied more money than
they would actually pay you and it
didn't take into consideration if you
made them more money it didn't take into
consideration how much money you made
them it didn't take into consideration
if you were banned from Facebook but
Facebook generated no Revenue it still
penalized you that's part of it so
here's what I'm here's what I'm hearing
here's what I'm thinking if the question
is
and I do have I do have qualms about
recording the recording but we'll get
into more detail they say you were you
were supposed to be friends why would
you record your friend's phone call
well that's an interesting point to be
made why would your friend send you a a
very very bad contract that that felt
exploitative and why would a friend not
listen to you when you say take me off
the table it's not a fit there was never
just to be clear there was never another
offer that came through after I said
these are the non-starters the penalties
for big Tech right these the owning of
people's names image likeness their
platforms which in perpetuity long after
they leave I said then we can talk about
the money right they he said they came
in low and I'm sure my my gay Cuban
hardcore right uh right-wing agent came
in high you find that but it's like but
there there can't be any terms without
this once I said that can't happen then
these terms the big Tech penalties
that's when so the talks completely
stopped it was never changed and said of
course all these it's like you saw in
the first video we have to make money
they outright said that fee structure
couldn't be changed yeah there was never
another offer after that I said look
this is the sticking point you have to
get rid of all of these change it and
also you have to we can't do this I'd
love to sit as from one business owner
to another you don't have to do it this
way right a good example is look and I
feel vulgar talking about numbers
election night okay election night we
had been suspended for having Carrie
Lake on the entire daily wirecast on
YouTube less than a quarter of the
viewers that we had on Rumble when we
cross streams their viewership went up
40 that 30 40 000 people that's proof of
product that hey look proof of concept
you can do it off of YouTube you don't
have to right I think you use the
platform as long as you can but you need
to start building Alternatives it is
fundamental to the business model on the
right to not change that and I'll just
point out that we have about 120 000
more live viewers than we average with
you being here so there's something I
think daily wire's got some creative
like a lot of opportunity on their
website because like if all your back
catalog was on daily wire at no cost
anybody and they could go into daily y
login and then I spend 99 cents on a
Crowder video and then that money gets
split between you guys like there's a
lot of technical well they're already
doing over 300 000 mug subscribers day
one right now
um the the issue here is let's take me
out of it let's say you're starting your
own thing right you're trying to come up
in this movement and the terms are being
set by people on your side behind the
scenes where this is the ball that you
have to play I said did you mean take me
out of it it's not the right foot which
I thought if I don't have a dog in this
fight anymore it won't fall on deaf ears
when I say hey it's about the it's about
the next kid this can't work we can't
have a movement we can't sell our people
out and that's how I view it maybe you
don't they said this is just a business
these are the terms but there are
alternatives you don't have to be
dependent on YouTube or Facebook and you
certainly shouldn't make it fundamental
to your business model when you're
telling people that you're fighting them
it's going on for years here here's one
not just daily wire to be clear not just
daily wire
pick pick a name in the movement most
likely yes here's my view of it I think
the daily wire does important work good
work uh Candace Owens BLM documentary I
think was good uh What as a woman I
think was was a massive success that
that what has a woman reached people
that I know that aren't political and
that's that's a that's a cultural Force
so I think
I I I I talked with them we we had a
meeting I sat down with uh with Jeremy
with a few of the other guys but mostly
with Jeremy Jeremy came on the show
afterwards he said hey if there's
anything ever anything you ever need let
us know thanks for having me on and I
was like I'll hit you up sometime we
talked about doing uh Nashville week
because we wanted to we wanted to try
out our new mobile Studio then we got
you know while we're in the process of
setting this up I said well let's talk I
mean is there a way we can maximize the
effectiveness of our operations you guys
are way bigger than us of course but of
course as an opera there could be an
opportunity that we don't understand
that you do and so we started talking
about a variety of different things yeah
ultimately I it came to potential terms
it came to requirements
I of all the businesses I've ever
negotiated with the the most real in my
opinion was with Jeremy it was like I
was talking to an actual human being who
knew what he meant who explained the
pitfalls the pros and cons look if we do
a deal like this you're right it's going
to suck because of that reason that's
true what do you think and I said I
don't know if that's going to work for
us the joke is I I actually said what if
I want to put up a billboard that says
list chain is a fat pig and he was like
you know that's not us like we're not
and I couldn't find one big enough right
but but I said like I'm not literally
gonna do that you know it's I feel it is
kind of crude saying that point but the
point I'm trying to make is that we're
roguish we want to do weird things yeah
the ultimate conclusion was you know I
then there's maybe we can't work
transactionally together and I was like
yeah he's like but we'll do we'll do
other cool stuff sure you know we'll you
know we'll we'll talk with your your
guys on our shows you know we'll have
you on you can come on this will be
really great for everybody and so my
view was like I agree with you on the
contract stuff but why did it really
fall apart why did it completely Fall
Apart
like the deal with in other words what
you're saying is they were saying you
need to be in this box because it's not
about the billboard let's be honest it's
not just about the billboard well the
billboard was the box it was like if I
wanted to do something that was
aggressive and more shocking the
billboard is that point yeah I don't
want to put up a billboard calling list
Cheney a fat pig can I ask you something
yeah did they do the thing where they
said we tried to look at outside capital
for you for the first time at work they
didn't do that they didn't do that
I don't want to I don't want to give up
too much of the details of the
conversation we had of course but I
basically said uh let's just say I made
a big ask of the biggest asks that if if
if what you're saying you know it has to
be this way then I have a very very big
ask and they're like yeah that's
expensive I don't know if we can do that
and I was like look ultimately what it
comes down to is for those that
understand tabletop RPGs they play
Paladin I play Rogue someone commented
in super I understand the reference but
let's play right now do you not someone
someone super chatted they're trying to
be Rebels within the box they're
Warriors of God that's a paladin that
basically think of a stoic monk a knight
following the rules holding a sword
saying look the rules are as such we
will do right to the best of our
abilities whereas we here at timcast are
like a bunch of crackpots in the in the
bandits Forest being like we're gonna do
what we want to do it's like the lost
boys out here it's escape and you see a
bunch of mopeds and I thought you're
gonna throw a basketball in my face
asked me to play one of the yellow
Banger I did bring it to the basketball
court you did yeah VIP up the half up
yeah you know I would agree with you if
here's the problem when you have a few
because it's again this is not about the
daily wire there are a few few key
companies that control what is
permissible in this movement and these
two key a few key companies are saying
this is the only way I'm saying there
could be many ways it would be one thing
if we're saying hey maybe this way maybe
this other way but now this sort of
reeks of why don't you go and create
your own YouTube why don't you go and
create your own fine billionaire
investors to give you seed money well
how do you do that when then this
happens a lot ideas are stolen and then
Millions pumped behind it to promote it
as though it seems original and then
they steal your talent who you Foster
you know you you've probably had this
happen I've had it happen with dozens of
people the picture I sent you of people
working at her company there's at least
four or five there who worked for me
they were young other big networks in
this space came in offered them a bunch
of money I said look I'm not going to
keep you I give you a letter of
recommendation after six months they
come back
so I I wanted to address what you were
just saying about these companies
playing by the rules that's completely
my experience with a lot of these
different companies is that big Tech is
clearly infiltrated by I mean you look
uh Alan bakari I think it was got a hand
got his hands on that Google video where
they were crying that Trump won this is
Google
I love this on my Wikipedia it says Tim
Poole you know maintains that can
there's a bias in big Tech against
conservatives or whatever sure and I'm
like no I don't I read a Gizmodo article
from 2016 that said Facebook was
suspending conservative news I was in
there yeah that's how I met by half
agent Laura Bill Richmond he read the
article and he was like yeah it's like
the Chris Kyle Foundation Ted Cruz for
president and you uh you need some
representation they they they act like
it was a smear against me that I was
pushing conspiracy theories when I was
literally reading the left news sources
so so anyway
told you they set these terms these big
tech companies and then what happens is
the leftist organizations Clearly say
the stupidest and craziest things you
know chat GPT the AI bot it was I think
Jack besobic who asked it or he tweeted
this out when asked did Joy read and
Rachel Maddow spread covered
misinformation it says no they didn't
and it was like well they they did
literally we know for a fact they did
yes and then it goes out says well while
they acknowledge some mistakes no no the
whole machine is skewed in that
direction what happens then is Big tech
company I should say big Tech I'm sorry
many of these big conservative Outlets I
shouldn't even say necessarily
conservative Outlets but many of these
many of these companies are just like
we're going to set the parameters right
here because we're going to be within
the Box we're gonna be rebels in the Box
this is the problem and I'm finding why
I think Candace was pissed too is that
when we refer to companies doing thing
and what happens is the company is a
hologram it doesn't have any
availability or or any ability to do
anything the people so when you're
negotiating for instance it comes out
Stephen Crowder negotiating with the
daily wire quote right and that brings
all these other daily wire employees
into it like they were getting messages
Candace was Michael knows on their chats
and they're like now I'm involved
because it was between you and Jeremy
boring they don't have Ben Shapiro
there's actually four owners to the
Daily wire Ferris Wilkes and Caleb
Robinson owned by bent key Venture so
you're only in negotiation with four
people if we stopped saying YouTube is
doing this we're gonna get a lot more
accurate in the people who's doing it
who's who's using YouTube as a is a
filler yeah I want to know and I also
that leaves out unnecessary collateral
damage yeah well like I said it's like
they send out on YouTube you know they
send out representatives to
conservatives and they're patsies for
the higher-ups but when you you get
coming back to you time and time again
you know if you did what company X if
you did what company meaning big
conservative companies who have meetings
with them as if you did that we might be
able to get you remonetized or at least
not suspended and that's what I mean
this is the thing is there any examples
you could give us about key issues uh
specifically about that yeah anything
relating you know back in the day on
trans issues you know for example we had
a character like we did for a long long
time bang was a character that we
did was Bane dark knight series and all
I did was an uprising you know Arkham
Asylum against YouTubers so you can't do
that anymore
um there's one where they said you can't
sell off-site the socialism shirt that
we had which wasn't even on YouTube uh
yeah the the the social elements for
fake shirt you don't want to know the
funny story about that I've never seen
John laugh so hard was we started
selling on the website because it's
social limits for figs it's a plan where
you may not like it but people also need
to know Che Guevara executed gays right
this is a guy if when you wear a chick
of air shirt you're wearing a Hitler who
was less successful in being charismatic
and duping people not saying it was
successful I'm saying he was a genocidal
Maniac so of course we're mocking him
says well you can't do that that shirt
is hate speech it's off the platform so
what we ended up selling at the Crowder
shop was a mystery box
and I get a call from one of the most
senior Executives at YouTube and I go
what do
we know what's in the box
I think it's someone in Silicon Valley
is opening it like
completely off the platform but the
point is right you need to be there
needs to be someone standing up to these
giant organizations and when you say
like Jeremy said in this video well you
know we've only met with Susan macheski
once and we were really going in and
defending Stephen let's say okay one
second are you the biggest most
influential fastest growing conservative
Network in the world or did you spend
time going in and fighting for the
little guy were completely ineffectual
you can't have both one of those things
is true the inconsistencies are the
issue and that's a tactic of the left
here's like fully expect them to come
out and say this is a lie This Is A Lie
switched the narrative from the phone
call switched in there from the money
now that that's gone probably a Hit List
like the Vox adpocalypse probably get
personal this is why people don't speak
out this is why good people don't run
for office and we shouldn't be doing
that on the right thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time